biden white house is considering a new
plan to stop the record surge at the
border
sending migrants cash not to come the
administration's weighing handing out
taxpayer dollars to central american
countries
to stop the flow of illegal immigrants
the program would address economic
issues in guatemala honduras and el
salvador
but it's unclear how exactly these money
transfers would work
and we have new video from congressman
steve scalise that shows a
jam-packed migrant children facility
dana don't we already send hundreds of
millions of dollars to central american
countries and don't the politicians down
there just
pocket it would these just be like
direct payments to to bank accounts
of people that i don't know whether they
have bank of america down there you just
wire it
straight there so i think that this um
if this policy is going to go through
they're going to obviously have to give
us a lot more detail as to how this
would work
uh so in terms of foreign aid yes i
can't remember the details but i
remember that president trump
threatened to take some away if the
company the countries didn't cooperate
with us and trying to stop the migrant
flow
and i can't exactly remember how all
that worked but yes there are
monies that go down there and then there
are accusations that some governments
down there
are very corrupt um and so that's
actually also one of the reasons that
people want to leave because there's no
law and order there
this idea of sending them direct
payments uh tom homan who used to be the
director of ice under obama and trump
he said this morning that if you do that
then they'll just use that money to
pay the smugglers and the coyotes to get
them across the border
it was like that's actually not going to
deter them from coming
right and then when they get to new york
city you get a cash payment here if
you're an illegal immigrant
greg you know why don't we just pay
criminals not to commit crime here in
the united states
i think they actually are trying that
somewhere it's like so joe biden
has decided to replace a wall with
paypal
i mean think about this think about this
like he did he decided to dismantle
all of the disincentives that trump
pretty much put there from the concrete
i.e wall to the uh policy remain in
mexico
to the actual rhetoric which was enough
to dissuade people from coming
then you see this crisis explode and
what do they do they throw taxpayer
money
at the problem they're literally paying
the problem to go away
by the way i will i'm wondering because
we talked about language changes
uh we're no longer saying cages or
crates i hear
they're now shelters we're now having
them in shelters
next week it'll be luxury boxes
i wonder if the infrastructure spending
yeah
accounts for the kids in cages all right
katie but
like greg said this is the perfect
democrat philosophy
throw money at a problem and hope it
goes away
well i knew when roberto jacobson who is
the now leaving southern border
coordinator
got up in front of the white house press
corps and essentially said the problem
with crime
in the northern triangle was that they
didn't have enough street light street
lights and that we needed to send them
more money for infrastructure
in those countries that they were in big
trouble the reason why president trump
was able to stop the flow from central
america is precisely because he froze
450 million dollars in payments to those
countries or billion dollars i believe
maybe it was billions of dollars a lot
of money is the bottom line and if you
look at the record of the people who are
running the show down there
the former president of honduras was
arrested for trafficking kane into the
united states
just in march there was a former
honduran congressman who was sentenced
to life in prison for
trafficking 185
million tons 185 tons into the united
states of cocaine he also got arrested
on firearms charges
last fall 700 people were arrested in
all of the northern triangle countries
el salvador guatemala and honduras
all for similar crimes so imagine being
a taxpayer
who is spending all this money to the
federal government you asked for
this 1400 stimulus check you don't get
it and all of a sudden
you're paying money to go to the pockets
of corrupt
regimes like this with nothing in return
bad deal
all right so jessica and this trial
balloon
kind of makes it obvious they have no
clue what to do
with this crisis what would president
tarloff do to stop the flow
i do like the sound of that and i am
over 35
which i hate to admit but i'm going to
be the most powerful woman in the world
um listen i i don't think that the game
about
you know the semantics of is it a crisis
it's not we're seeing a record surge
here
the migrant detention facilities are a
veritable disaster we've opened up nine
new ones we need to make sure that
everyone who is seeking legal asylum and
i want to be clear
this is their legal right to do this can
be well taken care of and can have their
day in court to see if they should be
let in here
but what's going on with the trial
balloon about the cash payments and the
broader
uh policy as it goes with the northern
trial triangle in mexico
is quarter what vice president harris is
trying to do and she's been in
communication with the leaders of all
these countries and has actually gotten
quite a positive response including an
extra 10 000 troops
from mexico on the border increased
policing in the northern triangle
countries there is corruption
we need to know how this money would
reach the people who need it
but i would think that americans would
be happy that we're trying to keep them
where they are than to let them into the
country when we're seeing a surge like
this
oh i didn't hear about kamala harris
getting things under control
thank god you have me here my paternity
break
a lot went by during my break i'm glad
you caught me up to speed we have a fox
news alert